so how do we get these numbers in
percentages right here's what I'm gonna
do we're gonna do it for all three of
these numbers and get a common language
for all of them to get a fraction and
turn it into a percentage I'm gonna take
and we'll do this with the first number
we look with ultimately I'm going to
take in the month and I don't want to
change the number I just want to make it
look a little bit different just like
here right so that I can work with it
easier so I'm gonna multiply by 100%
okay now column assembly we just said
percent means out of 100
so what's 100 percent it's a hundred out
of a hundred a hundred thousand a
hundred years like this but 100 divided
by 100 is just one right so that's why I
can do this I'm multiplying by one I'm
not changing the number I'm just gonna
make it look a little bit different okay
so here's what I'm going to do just like
we were looking at before in our review
questions how can I simplify what I've
got over here what can I do with this
okay so I've got a common factor the
first common factor we've identified is
10 so if I divide this by 10 I get 4 and
if I divide this by 10 I just in fact I
could also say is it okay so that's good
can I go any further yeah I can't right
can I can I do another cancel yes
someone else can suggest something yeah
okay so I can divide by 2 that leaves me
with 2 here and this will become a 5
right can't I go any further than that
or am I finish I can go a little bit
further right what can I do yes
yeah good we've been working with this
this pair of numbers so far but this
pair of numbers I can also work with
right 34 divided by 2 is 17 right so
cancel cancel I get that for the 17 at
the top so I've done a lot of crossing
over like I can let me rewrite this a
little bit up on the left hand side
what's left of my
fraction is 17 what's left of this thing
over here what am i got that I've got 5%
right don't miss the percentage times 5%
okay how are multiples of 5 what are 17
fires what's a nice what's it's it's 85
one of the easy ways like thinking about
strategies is I know we have calculators
but 25 is really easy to do 20 of them
is equal to 100 and this is three fives
less than that which is au 5 then don't
forget percent so 3440 is 85% right now
I can do this same a conversion with the
other numbers the other pair can you do
that for me 36 at 45 and 21 out of 25
this process here I'll give you a bit of
a head start on me but I will do it on
the board too so with 36 out of 45 into
a percentage I'll remind you the first
step it looks like that can you guys
spend a couple of minutes to do that
don't skip any working and then get your
percentages if I simplify what okay I'm
gonna let you try you see what you get
I'll show you it's not hard to show the
number will look different it won't be a
percentage and it still won't have the
same denominator as any of these so it
ends up not being very useful for the
purpose that I want but it looks like
all I can cancel is to notice that to
try out the other two fractions and see
what you get do this one a little bit
quicker because the process is the same
as what we did last time and for the
lowest one I'm going to show you a bit
of a trick to do it okay now I don't
even have some answers
so I actually wanna get the working
first what's something I can cancel
what's that what's the biggest number I
can cancel your trip
okay I can cancel between these two
numbers what should i / I can I can
divide by five come on time right so if
I now divide this by 5 it leaves me with
no and then I divide this by 5 which
leaves me at work that's good okay I do
anything else I can write this is the
same thing that happened over here right
oh don't forget that numerator
don't leave him alone that's not fair on
him you can work with him as well so
that it seats / 9 he's gonna leave me
with 4 okay now that you see what's
going on 4 times 20% now this is a
percentage 80% okay so you can see okay
clearly out of the first five done 85%
is better here comes the last one now we
could do it exactly the same way -
adjusted the first two and if you did
that way
thumbs up you can confirm whether you
have the right answer with me in a
second I'm gonna do something a little
bit stickier right I want you to notice
percent right it means out of a hundred
that's literally what it means so
anytime I see out of a hundred I can
replace that and I can put a percent
sign okay so therefore when I look at
this right 21 over 25 if I can turn the
denominator into out of a hundred
instead of out of 25 then I've got my
percentage right away okay what could I
multiply the denominator by to turn it
into a hundred yes
it's very good so I only change the
number right so if you do something to
the bottom you got new to the top but
multiplied by four is great because that
means on the denominator
twenty-five times four is a hundred
what's my numerator so look this is 84
out of a hundred
but part of a hundred is what percent
means so I write this as 84% and you can
use this to your advantage
this was no part of a question but
suppose I quickly said to you suppose I
said hey can you tell me 3 out of 10 as
a percentage right this should be easy
to do right what I want them to
nominated me yeah ok so I'm gonna go to
buy a 10 by 10 so this is clearly 30
percent right what about say 49 out of
50 how could I quickly turn that yeah
I'm gonna double the numerator Dominator
that's gonna blow by 2 this is 98
percent so you can see I've got two
techniques that I've got and they're
breathing really great I can multiply
like this by 100 percent and cancel
cancel cancel or if the numbers nice 25
10 50 what do all of these have in
common
well this visit starts with yeah they're
all factored are hundreds super easy I
can just multiply by an easy number and
gets straight notices okay so any factor
of 100
2 4 5 10 20 25 and I'm alone you can
just do this
if I double that's gonna kill 98 not 99
okay
now I've just got one last thing to say
before we get into the exercise Trudy
join us a question okay so the title
we're ready for we're not quite ready
but this question up is fractions which
we've already seen before
percentages and yeah I want one more
decimals now I haven't written on them
on the board yeah
but let's get our calculator out because
I'm I told you these will be useful for
us right and the whole idea
we've just compared fractions and
percentages at the moment the whole idea
is these are all the same numbers but
you just look at them a little bit
differently you look at them differently
and if you look at them differently
sometimes it's easier to do particular
things right you see that with fractions
and percentages the decimals be they're
calculated I want you take any number
that's on the board any of the fractions
or percentages you see okay your
calculator does in fact have or at the
fraction button which you looked at and
it's got a percentage button as well so
you guys already know where the fraction
button is where's the percentage
bothered you see yeah yeah it's above
the left parenthesis okay well let's
just quickly write down because a lot of
these are easy right if I say punch in
85% into my calculator right 85% and
then I can't equals it should tell me
0.85 okay that's the decimal murder by
the way what nothing in 85 percent come
from like we started with something else
and then we've got to 85
it started with 34:40 so if you go to
your calculator and you type in 34
divided by 40 and you hit equals right
one of two things will have it depending
on what kind of calculator you've got
right it might tell you this it might
tell you that hands up if you're kinda
to tell you that once you put the
fractional right yes okay thinking hands
down
alternatively it will take you straight
there now if you want to go back and
forth it's easy there's a button on your
calculator that looks like this and you
should have seen it before
so this translates back and forth
between fractions and decimals I don't
know why it's not fnd I don't there
still